It's time for "Dear Drew"
and we have a very special guest joining us today.
He is known for playing Kevin G,
the rapping mathlete in "Mean Girls"
and he's also made a name for himself on Instagram,
displaying his calligraphy art with pen pals,
he has all around the country.
Please welcome the creator of "Letters in Ink,"
Rajiv Surendra.
(audience cheering)
We here at "Dear Drew" usually start the segment with,
we call it the Zip Code of the Day.
And today's zip code is 27606,
Raleigh, North Carolina.
That's right.
(audience applauding)
And it is home of our affiliate station,
WRAZ Fox 50.
Home to more than 40 free historic attractions and museums,
Raleigh is also known as the Smithsonian of the South.
That's cool.
From paintings to pints, the Raleigh Beer Garden
in the Guinness Book of World Records,
has the largest selection of beers on tap
with over 360 to choose from.
Cheers.
Cheers to you, Raleigh.
North Carolina, we would love to hear from you.
Please write us a letter.
(audience applauding)
All right.
Let's open our first letter.
Ooh, this is more than a letter.
Ooh, I am loving this already.
I'm a tie-dye sock enthusiast!
This person gets me, they know me.
Dear Drew,
I couldn't think of anyone that loves flowers
as much as I do, besides you.
Enclosed are a few items
that have been naturally dyed using flowers
and botanicals that I make
and sell online at michellemooredesigns.com.
Michelle. Kingston, New York.
Oh.
That's so beautiful.
Okay. These are incredible.
I really am, by the way, Michelle,
a huge tie-dye sock enthusiast
and the fact that it came from flowers is so romantic.
I mean,
wow!
And we're gonna put your store on our website,
michellemooredesigns.com
so that we can feature you
in our "Little Book of Small Businesses Gift Guide."
Rajiv, your letter.
(paper crinkling)
Hi Rajiv,
I had the greatest pleasure
of discovering your "Letter Writing is Not Dead" video.
There is something truly magical
and sentimental about writing someone a letter.
Jamil. Harrison, New Jersey.
Oh, I love that.
Oh, Jamil.
(audience applauding)
How does it feel that this is really taking off
and connecting people?
I'm so honored.
I have been handwriting since I was a little kid
and it turned into calligraphy.
The question that I get asked most often
is how do I start to learn calligraphy?
Will you teach me something?
Because I've never done it.
Shall we do a little demo?
Yeah.
Shall I show you a little something?
Yes.
Okay.
So we're gonna start by just like a stretch.
(audience laughing)
I want you to move your arms,
move your arms.
Exactly.
Exactly. Okay, now let's take it to the board.
(audience cheering)
So this is what we're gonna do.
We're gonna make ovals
but we're gonna make them on us on a 52 degrees slant.
So watch me.
We're just gonna go like this and use your whole arm.
(chalk scratching board)
Good.
So once you've kind of loosened up,
we're gonna go to our letter forms.
Okay.
Let's do a D.
So watch me.
We're gonna start with a stroke that goes down.
I'm gonna make a little loop.
I'm gonna go down and then up and down.
Nice!
And now let's put in the R-E-W.
Nice.
If you keep practicing, let me show you
what it will look like
in a few years, okay?
All right, yeah, you-
I'm gonna show you.
(chalk scratching board)
I ran out of room, but-
(audience cheering)
Don't look, turn around.
Okay. Let's turn around.
Lets do our separate versions of it.
(chalk scratching board)
That's my signature.
Look how beautiful that is.
Oh my God.
This is so special.
(audience cheering)
Ow.
All right.
We've got one more letter
and this one is from Linda
from Sudbury, Massachusetts.
I wanted to write you to thank you for developing your show.
I'm a 74 year old grandmother who lives alone
and you brought much comical fun, and happiness to my life.
P.S. Yellow is my favorite color too.
See by a few pictures of my yellow belongings.
Linda. Sudbury, Massachusetts.
Oh, look at her beautiful-
(audience sighing)
Oh!
(audience applauding)
I mean, I didn't know what she was gonna say
but we are gonna actually surprise her on Zoom.
She thinks she's gonna talk to a producer from our show
but we're gonna surprise her.
Nice!
High five.
Okay.
(audience cheering)
Hello, Linda. Are you there?
I am. Hi, Drew!
Hi, Linda!
(audience cheering)
Oh, Linda!
You look so beautiful with your yellow beads
and your yellow shirt.
And my yellow glass
and my yellow phone.
Wow.
Oh, I'm so happy to meet you!
Ah.
Linda, I have this basket of yellow swag from our show,
but if it's okay,
you'll have to come by and get it.
So we would love to bring you and your best girlfriend
to a taping of the show right here in the city
and include you in the show
and have you be our special guests.
And then afterwards, we wanna send you out
to a fabulous, fancy dinner in the city.
Oh, and a spa too.
(audience cheering)
Okay. Michelle, Linda, and Jamil.
Thank you for your letters so much.
Here are our postcards to you
and we're gonna stick them right here in the mailbox.
Truly yours, Drew, and-
Rajiv.
(upbeat music)